[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american comedy film
called accepted spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
[Music]
bartleby gaines is a senior at william
mckinley high school in ohio he is
popular among his peers as the guy who
makes fake ids he is about to graduate
high school and has applied to seven
different colleges unfortunately for him
he has been rejected by all seven of
them in the opening scene he along with
his friends daryl and sherman are taking
pictures of their classmates to create
their fake ids daryl is a former
football player who now uses crutches
because of a permanent injury he has
recently lost his sports scholarship and
has no idea what he wants to do in life
in contrast sherman is a bright student
aiming to join the prestigious harman
college he is the fourth generation from
his family to be accepted to harmon
hence it is a big deal for his family's
reputation sherman disapproves of
bartleby's side hustle and warns him of
the principal who routinely comes to the
classroom in the eighth period as they
ask everyone to come back later the
principal enters the room bartleby saves
the group by pretending that they're
practicing for a glee club although the
group sings awfully the principal is
scared of glee club so he accepts the
story and lets them go on their way out
bartleby tells sherman that he has
applied to the eighth and the last
college the ohio state university he
hopes to get into it because if not he
will officially be the black sheep of
the family suddenly bartleby bumps into
a classmate named monica she is popular
and kind a quality that he seems to like
she tells him about a house party that
she is hosting the next day while
bartleby anticipates an invitation he is
asked to mow her lawn instead he is so
smitten by her that he happily agrees to
do so bartleby has had a crush on her
for a long time but monica is currently
dating a rich and popular show-off
ambrose at home bartleby comes across
the news that he had been dreading to
get even the ohio state university has
rejected his application he tells his
sister lizzy who suggests he break the
news to his parents not wanting to
accept that he has failed he declares
that he doesn't want to go to college
because it is financially irresponsible
when his parents pressure him to do the
opposite he admits that he has been
rejected by every college he applied to
they almost can't believe it it is clear
that he is an embarrassment to them the
following day everyone attends a
graduation party for the class of 2006
while most of them are excited about the
next four years of college bartleby and
daryl are depressed they have no clue
what they're about to do with their
lives like them an ideal student named
rory is also stranded although she is a
great student she only applied to yale
and didn't get into it as bartleby is
about to head out sherman's father
invites him to a group of people they
congratulate sherman for getting into
harmon and ask bartleby what his plans
are he embarrassingly tells them the
truth after which the group falls into
an awkward silence his parents do
nothing but look at each other in
disappointment at night bartleby throws
away the rejection letters but while
handling a fake id he gets an idea if he
can make an authentic looking fake id it
wouldn't be much more difficult to
create a fake acceptance letter he puts
the idea into action and develops an
acceptance letter for a fictional
college called the south harmon
institute of technology commonly known
as the [ __ ] the following morning he
tells sherman about his genius idea
which sherman thinks is a recipe for
disaster but upon his best friend's
persistence he creates a fake website
for the college that looks legit and is
functional he unknowingly also creates a
feature that sends an acceptance email
to everyone that applies daryl who is
just as distressed as bartleby also
joins the fake college when bartleby's
parents find out about the acceptance
letter they're ecstatic but most of all
relieved mr gaines thinks it is strange
that he has never heard of the [ __ ]
college bartleby convinces him that it
is legit by asking him to check out the
website since the college is a wing of
the prestigious harmon college the
parents believe that it is just as good
after getting a look at the website mr
gaines hands bartleby a check for ten
thousand dollars for his tuition fee
everything goes well until the couple
claims that they want to drop bartleby
off at his college dorm now he will have
to find a place that will pass off as a
college for a day as bartleby sherman
and daryl discuss the plan rory claims
that she knows an excellent place they
can use as a college she agrees to help
if they give her an acceptance letter
too the said excellent place is an
abandoned psychiatric hospital it is in
ruins so the group renovates it starting
the next day they turn the wards into
dorm rooms and the lounge area into a
hallway but refrain from entering the
bathroom that is in shambles they also
only clean the places that the parents
are likely to visit and leave the rest
as it is
in the meantime sherman moves into a
real college dorm in harmon the dean
wants to make a grand entrance way in
front of the college by expanding its
territory for this purpose the college
will have to buy the properties that
they want to take over this also
includes the fake college that bartleby
is currently renovating monica's
boyfriend ambrose is the head of the
student outreach committee the dean
keeps him in charge to secure the
properties required for the entrance way
he immediately gets on the job and is
soon about to cross paths with bartleby
meanwhile bartleby and the group are in
need of a fake dean for their fake
college they hire a former professor ben
who was kicked out and blacklisted
because of his temper although the man
isn't reliable bartleby hopes he will
get the job done then the following day
bartleby comes to the college with his
parents to make it look legitimate rory
has gathered a bunch of actors who
pretend to be moving into the dorm
bartleby's parents take a tour of the
place and find it average thankfully for
him they do not divert to the
unrenovated rooms following that they
meet the dean who curses and throws
profanities at the education system
initially the couple is skeptical about
leaving their son with such an influence
but when he promises to land bartleby a
high-paying good job they are satisfied
later that day the group is hanging out
at the college when a guy comes in with
an acceptance letter it turns out that
he sent an application to the website
and was selected by its automated
process as bartleby tries to explain
that the college doesn't actually exist
he notices a crowd of people behind the
guy for a few seconds he freezes in
shock at the sight the people ignore him
entirely and enter their new college
bartleby immediately goes to meet
sherman at the harmon college entrance
party sherman feels out of place between
the rich kids who frequently make fun of
him he and bartleby return to south
harmon and find a bag of tuition fees
submitted by the students when the
students gather in an auditorium-like
place bartleby goes in front to announce
the truth but seeing their hopeful faces
reminds him of himself south harmon is
their last chance at getting into a
college and he doesn't want to take that
away from them hence he refrains from
telling them the truth the next day the
pool is filled and the entire college
turns into a big pool party they do not
have a syllabus to go by hence to make
one everyone writes what they want to
learn on a whiteboard some people want
to cook while others are interested in
skating fashion design and so on some
students say they want to learn to blow
things up with their minds but bartleby
allows them to express their creativity
he encourages everyone to learn whatever
they want to and provides them resources
using the tuition fees soon south harmon
becomes a place for all losers to pursue
their dreams one day ambrose comes to
meet the leaseholder of the property
wanting to buy it for harman's college
entryway expansion bartleby declares
that the property won't be sold and
sends him back without an explanation in
harmon college sherman is so desperate
to get into the fraternity house that he
does everything his bullies say they
even make him wear stupid costumes and
ask him to drink their spit during a
party monica who also goes to harmon
arrives at the fraternity house to her
horror she finds ambrose making out with
another girl he tries to explain the
situation but she refuses to listen and
storms off the next day she finds a
camera in her room gifted by bartleby
monica is impressed that he remembered
she likes photography she goes to south
harmon to thank him and comes across the
strange curriculum and even stranger way
of teaching initially the college seems
to be a joke but as she gets to know
more about it she thinks the idea is
genius sherman is worried that if more
people get to know about the college
bartleby might get sued seeing that
bartleby doesn't care about the legal
channels he applies for the college to
get accredited he wants to make sure
they have a case to appeal if they ever
get sued that night south harmon
organizes a huge party with a live
concert and free drinks both managed by
the students the word about the party
goes around and even the students from
harman join in the same night ambrose
also organizes the alleged biggest party
of the year but no one shows up he
doesn't have to dig a lot to find out
that his guests went to south harmon's
party he and his group go to south
harmon to see what the fuss is about
monica and bartleby are also at the
party enjoying themselves bartleby
brings her to his room and shows her
around eventually they end up kissing
bartleby gets a text from sherman
informing him of ambrose's arrival when
the rival group spots monica in the
crowd they feel betrayed monica on the
other hand tells them that she is
transferring to south harmon ambrose and
his group leave after being humiliated
the next day they trick sherman into
coming to the frat house and beat him up
until he tells them the reality of south
harmon college after finding out the
truth ambrose doesn't waste a day before
planning south harmon's and bartleby's
downfall the next day all the parents
arrive at the college upon ambrose's
request as bartleby tries to find out
what is happening the police arrive and
disclose that the college is a scam
bartleby is sued for embezzling money
and establishing an organization without
proper documentation his parents who are
also in the crowd can almost not believe
it all the other parents take their
children back home just when bartleby
gives up on the college sherman informs
him that they still have a chance he has
appealed for a college license to the
state accreditation board if they are
able to prove that they are a legitimate
educational organization they will get
the license and south harmon will
continue to exist on the day of the
hearing all the students come to court
it is revealed that to be accredited as
a legitimate educational institution
south harmon must have a facility a
curriculum and a faculty when asked
about what facilities his college
provides bartleby lists out things like
the dorm room the tiki bar the common
rooms and the skateboard ramp however
the board argues a library or a
cafeteria is a must for the curriculum
part the infamous whiteboard is brought
to the court it has absurd things
written on it that bartleby tries to
explain but the board remains
unimpressed the last straw for the board
is when it finds out there are no
teachers in the college because the
students learn from each other bartleby
knows that the lawsuit is slipping from
his hands he stops the court process and
apologizes to everyone for lying to them
but he is also adamant about the fact
that the students of south harman
learned while they were in the
institution they were being taught
things that they were interested in
which should be the main aim of all
educational institutions the college was
fake but it did not affect the student's
education which is why he thinks that
they should be given a chance to
officially prove themselves the judges
are impressed by the speech moreover the
students won't have a place to go in the
middle of the semester hence they are
granted a one-year probationary period
to continue their experimental program
everyone celebrates the win and south
harmon goes back to being the fun place
for learning subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching